so the music video right you know i took
what i'd like observed you doing for our
music videos tried to be as prepared as
possible right i've never thought about
that sort of stuff before right coming
up with a shot list you know creating a
little narrative in whatever like world
we were going for how to make the first
course different from the second course
all that stuff right try to think it all
out and it was like a learning
experience right you know we had to wrap
it like 5 and a 4 30. i look at the dp i
was like we've got we have like 10 we're
like looking at the shot list together
we're like
[ __ ] anything yeah like how does this
happen every single time set life
hashtag set life yeah man sat live
satellites fun bleeding money what the
[ __ ] is the point of your existence oh
yeah feeling like it's all a waste yeah
why did i pay for all this [ __ ] to do
this dumb ass idea just to cut it and
put it out there and someone would be
like lol youtuber music
now you're right man this is music on
youtube you're definitely right think
with music videos first of all when you
hear about big artists shooting their
music videos you always hear these
horror stories of 16 to 18 hour shoots
so first of all you had extras right yes
yeah so when you involve any degree of
cast whatever scene you think you're
gonna shoot out in 20 minutes with
extras it's an hour yeah hour and a half
at minimum yeah because let's say you
involve five to seven people there's a
weird thing when you bring in extras you
get the whole shot you go back to review
it and then you're like what the [ __ ] is
that guy like picking his nose you gotta
run the action again and then it's just
like it becomes like this you know self
feeding and then yeah now you're two
hours down on like one setup and then
like we'd start shooting oh this would
be funny oh this would be funny all that
take wasn't right that take wasn't right
redoing takes the extras were
hilarious man just like career extras
yeah they just like don't give a [ __ ]
about like etiquette and just like dude
every this one chick bless her heart she
was
a very very sweet woman but every time
we'd
cut i'd like go to the dp to get
playback and i'd walk by her and she'd
go yo turn your airdrop on i got 14 more
for you like what
turn your airdrop on come on okay it's
like so-and-so wants to send you 32
pictures it's like okay thanks
except they come through it's just like
just like look at these [ __ ] pictures
she's like this is a really good one oh
she's taking photos of the monitor yeah
and i'm just of me and of everyone
wow okay and sending them to me every
single time i'd walk by i should be like
just turn your drop on that's very sweet
it's awesome it's very sweet it was
awesome but like also we're like pressed
for time and i'm just trying to see
playback yeah and she'd be like oh this
one's really good and i'm like yep
that's what that's really good guys
two seconds over here yeah yeah that's
why elena always makes fun of me when i
go into director mode and i become very
like cut and dry and uh i'll tune people
out
yep i get it i totally get it and then
people will tell me things and i'll
process them but then i just walk past
them and they're like did you hear yeah
i got just
rat race was interesting because i i
feel like in terms of uh execution that
was one of my sharpest yet because i
when i scouted i was able to go in i'm
like okay i'm just gonna put a light
here like here like here we lit the
whole place in a couple hours and then
it was just lit for the rest of the day
yeah yeah which is easy to do because
it's like a warehouse scene and you know
we i went black and white because that
way you're not really worried about
dialing in the colors
and so that was like one of the like
enjoyable experiences directing but yeah
when you're when you deal with a ton of
people it just you almost need like two
days sometimes oh yeah for sure because
it's it's just it's so much i loved it
though no it's definitely fun i was just
like not gonna stress about it if it
turns out shitty i don't really care
sure it's gonna be something yeah and
that's better than nothing yeah yeah to
me i'm dreading seeing the cut it's it's
like a very like pit in the stomach like
i hope it's okay it's not gonna be i
know just we didn't get anything for
like the second half of the song
no performance takes nothing
so it's just going to be like random
footage i guess yeah rat race was crazy
because that's the first time you know
bless nima's heart always trying to do a
million [ __ ] thing is always trying
to do a million things like he's always
trying to be more than the dp and it's
like like it's like relax bro like
you're being paid to do one job and
you're because he just cares so much but
it was really sick because we shot rat
race that whole thing where like the
camera was like flying by me we did that
practically like with the steadicam okay
it was like an idea i'd come up with and
then nemo during lunch he he drops the
card and he's like editing it on set
never really had that before and so it
was just to see the effect working and
it's like yeah it definitely works elena
all the projects she's worked on they
[ __ ] they're cutting like in real
time so they know what they're doing is
working dude it's crazy she worked on
apple stuff but she was saying that
and i pref i say that to say like they
have like a bazillion dollars while they
shoot they had it down so they were
dropping cards in real time and they
have an editor on standby and they're
uploading the footage as they're
shooting and then it's like within 24
hours they get a cut sometimes they get
a cut end of day because like the script
and the storyboard it's like it's it's
so dialed in and so as a director you
can walk in there with a [ __ ] ton of
confidence because you're like ah we'll
get a cut by end of day and there's a
chance we can extend and you know we can
you know get we can call everyone in
tomorrow and like get this and it's just
it's crazy yeah man congrats yeah thanks
your first one in the can thanks yeah
let's just see how much just try
shooting giant steaming turd it is yeah
yeah yeah i would love to film it is a
lot of fun yeah it's a lot of fun don't
they've like developed that in the dark
room right yes just shoot somewhere with
a dark room yeah apple had dark rooms
yeah just dark rooms on set yeah they
brought a trailer and they were yeah
it's so funny when we're uh packaging up
the film when we were done shooting and
they have to do it in this little tent
so it doesn't like get exposed to light
yeah and it just it looks like uh like a
mr beast like what's in the like stick
your hand through okay guess what it is
like remember walking by the dude he's
got his hands in this [ __ ] tent just
like feeling around like trying to undo
the can and pull the film out and load
it and the other [ __ ] and it's like this
just looks so [ __ ] weird yeah guy
over at a desk what's in there pudding
or are you transferring the film no i
just have jelly of jello in here put a
dildo in there as a prank yeah what the
[ __ ] is
hurry up man hurry up hurry up we got
let's go let's go we gotta we gotta rap
film is sketchy too because the monitor
just it's like this [ __ ]
x-wing stuttered image you're kind of
looking at and you're like i think that
will look good yeah getting that footage
back was just
i'm gonna throw up if this is bad yeah
i'm dreading seeing there we definitely
got some really funny stuff yeah of
course some stuff just ended it just
wasn't planned you know like it just was
like oh let's do this this would be
funny just game time decisions that [ __ ]
up everything you know it was a lot of
that stuff so yeah you have to cut those
like you have to do one or two nema
that's where he and i feel like we
balance really well because nemo will
always throw ideas out there and then
i'll always
i have a tendency to be like no when
nemo throws out an idea sometimes that
ends up being a really great idea and
but then i feel like i also do a good
job of being like we just gotta we gotta
get it and yeah we got to get the vision
man yeah gotta get the whole concept
vision it's it's tough i mean filmmaking
you know one of the most distinct extras
like he's got a look people like
recognize him from he's worked a lot
like okay he gets hired a lot the first
thing he says to me is like oh it was in
a jake paul video i was like really yeah
i played a kidnapper i was like okay
that's cool he's like yeah it was cool
sick like i got recognized one time i
was like did you he's like yeah some mom
came into the supermarket and was like
oh are you really a kidnapper whoa and
he was like proud of it and i was like i
don't know yeah i'm a kidnapper man my
favorite thing to do is to yell at
everyone that they're not moving fast
enough yeah unironically yeah first 10
seconds on set what the [ __ ] is everyone
doing no lunch today by the way yeah
telling the steady off that he's out of
shape
hey man um
i'm not going to tell you you're killing
it because you're not uh are you
sweating so much dude listen man i just
want to give you this it's my 24 hour
gym membership
why don't you cut out here an hour early
and hit the treadmill let's get that
endurance up and i never want to see you
here again